[Musik]
dieser Youngtimer kostet ein Vermögen
für die einen eine alte Klapperkiste für
die anderen eine autolegende in England
wird ein 40 Jahre alter Peugeot
versteigert Mindestgebot rund
270.000 € dabei hat der Kleinwagen
1984 gerade mal 44 000 € gekostet doch
jetzt ist der wohl plötzlich ein
Vermögen wert zumindest unter
autosammlern die Turbo 16 Straßenversion
des Peugeot 205 wurde damals nur 200 Mal
produziert der zu versteigernde Peugeot
ist Nummer
176 also extrem selten montiert wurde
wie bei der Baureihe üblich alles in
Handarbeit der
197 PS Motor sitzt im Kofferraum von 0
auf 100 beschleunigt der Wagen in 6,6
Sekunden Spitzengeschwindigkeit 220
stundenkilm in in den Jahren 1985 und 86
hat der Peugeot 205 Turbo 16 sogar Rally
WM Titel eingefahren eine echte Legende
also die Versteigerung des kleinen
Flitzers kann Ende Februar als
Livestream verfolgt werden auch in
Deutschland soll das mitbieten online
möglich sein doch ob der kleine Flitzer
bei dem stolzen Preis wirklich einen
neuen Besitzer findet ist
unklar